what most kids will choose to do at 23  22 they could go be crazy three four  five six seven years and if it doesn't  work out go get that job that they would  have at 22. it's actually practical to  be high risk in your early 20s yet the  world told you you're now a grown-up go  ultra conservative usually based on  one's keeping up with the joneses or  appeasing their parents narrative both  are horrible ideas most kids don't have  the stomach to deal with the short-term  conflict they appease they do it they  wake up at 28 they aren't accountable  that they made the choice and they start  pointing fingers that their parents have  made them get the safe law job instead  of the high risk law job and it becomes  a whole cluster [ __ ]